what's the hardest part about being on  the road as much as you are over the  years the hardest part was missing your  family like missing my kids growing up  in that  but now the Fiona's marriage you may  meet her out there together so I never  have to tell her how lousy the hotel was  she's I think I have upgraded it a  little bit sure do you notice the  different classes of hotels you know if  it has if you don't have to unwrap the  cup in the bathroom you're staying in a  slightly nicer oh yeah  but that's the kind of stuff I throw in  the bag and take with me are you a  hoarder John Prine no no I use  everything I steal yeah I borrow like  taking silverware from mojo so Jack I  come home and feel fine it's wrapped up  in the napkin there's cheap yeah i order  something for myself I always tell them  that there's to dining so send an extra  set of silverware I take that one put on  my suitcase and then use the other one  you're always ready you never know  what's gonna happen